what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
eight Q&A video
I haven't made one of these videos in a
while so I figured it was time to answer
some more of the questions you may have
I made a post on my community tab and I
received over a hundred questions but
unfortunately I was only able to answer
a handful today because some of my
answers took a little longer than I
expected I will make another one of
these shortly so I can get to some more
of your questions but without wasting
any time today let's just jump right
into them the first question I want to
answer is from patreon and this will
take me a few minutes to explain so I
want to tackle this one right away
Nikki Sinclair's question says will the
stark name survive once the Great War is
over
John is a Targaryen and brain is the
three-eyed Raven so that only
realistically leaves songs and Aria but
this also relies on them surviving to
the end could the stark name disappear
could this be the bittersweet ending
okay this is a really great question and
this is something that concerns me
because I love House Stark
first I just want to say yes this could
be the bittersweet ending the stark
children could live which would be sweet
but if they don't reproduce and the
stark name dies with them then that
would be better however I think there is
a way to solve this problem people ask
me this question all the time and I have
actually answered this question in a Q&A
video before and I even made a video
about this topic around a year ago but
when I read your question last night he
gave me a new idea and now I have a new
answer to this question I made a video a
few days ago about Jon Snow and in that
video I read all the book quotes that I
could find about Jon Snow being the king
but one of those quotes may have the
answer to this question so I want to
read this to you again then I will tell
you how it relates to our current story
this actually isn't the first time House
Stark came close to going extinct but
thankfully many years ago an
illegitimate son was born and it ended
up saving House Stark and I think that's
what could happen again the funny thing
is when this story was introduced in the
books it was actually told to Jon Snow
and that was probably done for a very
important reason
when Jon Snow captured g-great she tells
him a story about a bastard from
Winterfell just like Jon Snow but this
story she tells him has some very
interesting parallels to our current
story and our current situation of House
Stark not having an heir to carry on the
name Yaeger tells John the story about
bail the bard who was the
king-beyond-the-wall at the time and
this is what she says bail the bard was
king-beyond-the-wall a long time back
the stark in Winterfell wanted bales
head but never could take him and the
taste of failure called him one day in
his bitterness he called bail a Craven
who prayed only on the weak when word of
that got back Bale Val to teach the Lord
a lesson so he scaled the wall skipped
down the Kings Road and walked into
Winterfell one winter's night with harp
and hand naming himself ski Greek of sky
goes ski Greek means deceiver in the old
tongue that the First Amendment still
speak north or south singers always find
already welcome so bale a tent Lord
Starks own table and played for the Lord
in his high seat until half the night
was gone the old songs he played in new
ones he'd made himself and he played in
saying so well that when he was done the
Lord offered to let him name his own
reward all I ask is a flower bale
answered the ferrous flower that blooms
in the gardens of Winterfell now as it
happened the winter roses had only then
come into bloom and no flower is so rare
nor precious so the Starks sent to his
glass Gardens and commanded that the
most beautiful ode the winter roses be
plucked for the singers payment and so
it was done but when the morning come
the singer had vanished and so had Lord
Brandon's maiden daughter her bed they
found empty but for the pale blue rose
that bill had left on the pillow where
her head had lain John had never heard
this tale before Lord Brandon had no
other children at his behest the black
crows flew forth from their castles in
the hundreds but nowhere could they find
any sign of bail or this made for most a
year they
urged til the Lord lost heart and took
to his bed and it seemed as though the
line of Starks was at its end but one
night as he lay waiting to die Lord
Brandon heard a child's cry he followed
the sound and found his daughter back in
her bedchamber asleep with a babe at her
breast they had been in Winterfell all
the time hiding with the dead beneath
the castle the maid loved bail so dearly
she bore him a son the song says Bale
left the child and payment for the rose
he'd plucked unasked and that boy grew
to be the next Lord stark now this story
is very important because of all the
parallels to the current story in the
recent Jon Snow video I made pointed out
how this story relates to Jon Snow's
parents bail the bard liked to sing and
play the harp
just like Rhaegar Bale the bard gave a
blue rose to the stark daughter just
like Rhaegar and the stark daughter fell
in love would Bale the bard
and bore him a bastard son just like
Liana did with Rhaegar that's why this
story was told to John because it
foreshadows his own birth but there was
something else mentioned in this story
that is key to the Starks current
problem in this story Ygritte tells Jon
she says Lord brandon was worried
because he had no other children and his
daughter went missing it looked like the
stark line was at its end because there
was no air to carry on the name but that
was until he found his daughter back in
her room with a baby boy laying on her
chest this baby was the bastard in
Winterfell just like John but the story
says this baby grew up to be Lord Stark
so they must have legitimized this baby
to save the stark house Lord Brandon's
daughter didn't marry Bale the bard she
just had his kid so technically the kid
should have had the last name snow but
they gave it the stark name anyway so
their house didn't go extinct what makes
this story so interesting is because we
have another bastard in Winterfell Jon
Snow who may have to save the stark
house from going extinct again how
ironic would it be if the bastard Jon
Snow was the one who produced a stark
heir for Winterfell
even though he is technically a
legitimate Targaryen Jon never saw him
self as a stark and he would even have
nightmares where he's standing in the
crypts of Winterfell and he would scream
to the dead kings of winter that he's
not a stark even lady Catelyn hated the
thought of this bastard being associated
with the Starks
but now the fate of this ancient house
may rest on his shoulders just like the
previous bastard in Winterfell did in
the story Ygritte had told Jon none of
the current Starks are sexually active
right now Sansa Arya and bran are all
single and we don't even know if bran
could have kids even if he wanted to in
Oriya has never had sex at all Sansa was
married a few times and unfortunately
she was raped by Ramsay but the
showrunners and producers already said
she is not pregnant so as of right now
that only leaves Jon Snow and we know
Jon has been having sex and there was
already a ton of foreshadowing that
leads me to believe Daenerys will be
pregnant with his child so I'm starting
to think John will do exactly what Lord
Brandon's daughter did to save the stark
name this would be history repeating
itself in this story once again this
would be the second time a bastard in
Winterfell saved the stark name though
cool thing about this is their baby
would be made up of Ice and Fire
so the stark line from here on out would
have a little bit of both of these
special bloodlines
I hope this answered your question Nikki
you definitely weren't the only person
who asked me how the Starks can save
their house from going extinct
I think the bail debarred story
foreshadows how the Starks will save
their line in the future it will be done
through the bastard and Winterfell just
like it was done before that's another
reason why this story was told to us in
a John chapter because it will
ultimately fall onto his shoulders and
the Starks house will be saved through
him but this is just my opinion the next
question is from Coolio 63 who do you
believe is the first major character to
die in the a season
I think the first major of death will
happen in the North now that the night
king is south of the wall he will be
taking out each town or village as he
works his way down to Winterfell
one of the first characters to die that
we know by name
we'll probably be little Ned umber or
Elise Karstark since they are directly
in the night Kings path and they will be
the first line of defense in the north
but they aren't major characters since
Miguel support Nick is directing episode
three that will probably be the first
big battle next season and this will
most likely be the start of the Great
War and this is when a main character
will die in my opinion we will lose
characters like grey worm and beric
Dondarrion right away beric Dondarrion
has been living on borrowed time ever
since season 3 or 4 so it's just a
matter of time before he dies he did
tell the Hound he would see him again
and this will probably be at Winterfell
during the Great War
berrak will likely saved someone's life
before he falls they have also been
building up this grey worm and missandei
relationship and when they do things
like this it's usually because they're
gonna kill one of the characters off
since grey worm will be fighting in the
battle he will probably be the one from
this relationship to die also during an
interview the showrunners were talking
about torment and Brienne and they were
talking about their relationship and how
all the fans enjoyed these characters
interactions with each other in this
show but they basically said they will
have to kill one of these characters off
before the end and if they were to do
this I think they would kill torment he
is actually lucky he survived the last
mission beyond the wall if it wasn't for
the Hound he would be dead
I think torment may find himself in a
similar situation and just when we think
torment will be saved again he won't and
this time he will die in battle
I would absolutely hate for this to
happen because I love torments character
but I'm afraid most of the Warriors will
die in the great war and they will start
to kill off characters at a fast rate
and I believe grey worm barrack and
maybe torment will be some of these main
characters to go first
the next question is from Tim f and he
says do you think the Hound will make it
out alive and start Westeros his first
all-you-can-eat chicken farm my answer
is yes in yes the Lord of Light has big
plans for Sandor Clegane and I don't
think he's going anywhere just yet this
character has been through one hell of a
metamorphosis and I believe he will make
it to the end The Hound falls under
the cripples bastards and broken things
and these are the characters that will
be needed in order to break the wheel
Daenerys cannot do this alone she will
need to help from all these underdogs I
have made a video specifically about
this topic before so I won't go into all
the details again but I think all the
characters that were featured in that
episode back in season 1 episode 4 will
be the characters that survived until
the very end no one expected any of them
to be in the position they are in now
but the fate of the entire realm is
resting on their shoulders and together
they will bring the dawn the night king
will be defeated and Cersei will be
removed from power Westeros will never
be the same again but they will give all
the survivors hope for a better world to
live in people will die sacrifices will
have to be made
castles will be destroyed and some of
the most powerful houses will come to an
end
but those who live will see a better day
this next question is from Doug back and
he says since the night king became
active just prior to or at the same time
as the beginning of the game of Thrones
series it has to be linked to something
or someone just prior to where the
series starts unless the night King has
Future Sight what's brand may have her
get he wouldn't have to known back then
of John Danny and the Dragons I think
the night King has always been tied into
the weirwood net and something he
learned through it and his working
beyond that I don't know enough good
lore from the books to postulate I kind
of think it's related to him being a
stark or stark ish okay what Doug is
talking about is why the night king has
decided to become active now something
had to have happened very recently for
the night King to start gathering his
troops to advance onto the wall I
believe it's all tied into the where
what net that I king was created by the
children of the forest and they all used
the where one net to see things in the
past and even see some events that will
unfold in the future this is how
Bloodraven always knew he would
eventually meet bran in the cave and
begin to train him himself to become the
next story a raven Bryan has also seen
bits and pieces of the future he has
seen the throne room destroyed and
covered in snow and he also seen the
Wildfire explode under the Sept the
night king uses
same weirwood system which we have seen
him used before when he touched bran and
once the night king went rogue and broke
off from the children he started to use
the weirwood net for himself and I think
he knew there were gonna be some very
special people coming to wipe him out in
the future characters like Brian John
and Daenerys I think the night King knew
they would eventually come so he is
reacting to them and that's why he
started to amass an army the night King
started to prepare for this day before
they were even born I don't think any of
this happened by accident or coincidence
Bloodraven has been manipulating the
events in Westeros for a very long time
and I think the night King was preparing
for this - that's why the night king
wanted to kill bloodraven so bad because
it was personal he knew bloodraven was
going to do everything in his power to
kill the others that's why the night
king walked straight into the cave and
took out bloodraven first that's why the
night king looked very pissed off when
he finally got his chance to come face
to face with the man who was moving all
the chess pieces to end the White
Walkers for good that's also how the
night King knew bran was gonna be there
in the vision it was a setup he knew
exactly where to catch bran to be able
to touch him and enter the cave to
finally kill Bloodraven then I King
knows when certain events were gonna
happen because he's seeing things
through the weirwood net - the night
King tried to spring a trap on John the
night king could have wiped out hardhome
and anytime that he wanted to but he
waited until John showed up because he
needs to kill John because he knows he's
one of the few characters that will
threaten the existence of the others he
also sprung the trap on Daenerys inner
dragons he was only able to kill one
dragon but he almost killed - none of
this is an accident in my opinion the
night King was waiting for this day to
come just like bloodraven was but now
it's up to bran to carry on that
knowledge this is another reason why I
think the night king is heading for
Winterfell because he knows everyone
will be there
brain especially the next question is
from low to a do you think when John
knows the truth about himself he will
let Daenerys claim the throne or not
because in the first season when a mole
and talked to John he said what is honor
compared to a woman's love what is Duty
against a feel of a newborn son in your
arms in this case maybe John will let
her get the
thrown and their son will not be a
bastard and if she is not pregnant
perhaps he would not make that decision
like a mom I know I've always felt this
way about John we all know he has no
desire to rule the Seven Kingdoms he
didn't even want to rule the Nights
Watch although he was happy that the men
thought he was fit to do so but it was
never his goal John wanted to be a
ranger not the ruler I think John will
basically do what Amon did John is
technically next in line but he will
refuse the position and give it to
Daenerys if she still wants to rule the
Seven Kingdoms by the end John will
probably help make some of the decisions
so all the people can live a better life
but I could never see him wanting to sit
on the Iron Throne and I don't even
think Daenerys will want the throne by
the end either
I think the Iron Throne will be
destroyed and they will split the
kingdoms up into different territories
but just to stay on track from the
original question I think John will pass
on the opportunity to roll like a moun
did and he will step aside for Daenerys
if she wants the position still but I
think they will figure out a new way to
keep things in order and make Westeros a
more civilized place to live I wanted to
try to keep this video under 20 minutes
long or else that will take over ten
hours to make so I'm gonna end this one
right here if you still have some
questions please put them down below and
I will make another Q&A video like this
I want to thank everyone that submitted
some questions and I want to thank all
of you for watching and I have to give a
special thanks to everyone on patreon
for continuing to support the channel I
really appreciate that and I hope you
all have a great day
I will see you in the next one bye
[Music]
[Music]